hello this is Steve Kaufman here I'm
going to do an experiment I'm going to
I'm gonna align this a little better I'm
going to speak clearly and slowly in
order to test the closed captioning
function at YouTube I'll speed it up a
little I think I have to avoid the
thumbs because that creates funny
symbols with the closed captioning I
want to see how this works I look
forward to hearing from you I'm going to
talk about speaking because I've had a
bit of an exchange a discussion with
Benny the Irish polyglot and we are in
fact hoping to do an online discussion
which we would record and offer as a
podcast where we will talk about about
our respective approaches to language
learning the issue is when should we
begin to speak when we're learning a
foreign language how well can we expect
to speak after one month two months
three months how long does it take to be
able to speak well what do you have to
do to be able to speak well those are
some of the things that I'm going to
talk about here let me first say that I
think anyone that's on the internet
promoting the learning of foreign
languages is a good guy so while I may
disagree with one or other of the people
in terms of method which is normal
because people have different ways of
doing things and the fact that one
person believes fervently in their own
method doesn't mean that someone else's
method is wrong nor should we be shy
about saying what we think so I say what
I think and Benny the Irish polyglot I'm
sure is not going to be timid about
saying what he thinks so that's fine
seem to have a difference in that he
very much encourages people to start
speaking from the beginning whereas I
say that I personally don't like doing
that but the people should speak when
they want to and I put the emphasis on a
lot of input listening reading to build
up vocabulary build up some familiarity
with the language otherwise I find that
engaging with someone in a foreign
language when I have very few words is
actually painful for me and painful for
the native speaker so I tend to avoid it
now of course if you're in a classroom
the teachers will tend to want to make
people speak because that's something
you're gonna do in a classroom
personally if I ran a classroom I'd let
the kids read or listen to their iPod
right in the classroom I think that's
more valuable for them I say that
without ever having tried that in a
classroom and maybe the kids would all
fall asleep I don't know I think the
first thing is when it comes to speaking
let me just say it say a few things that
come to mind right away in order to
learn to speak well you have to speak a
lot okay so at some point you have to
start speaking and you have to speak a
lot in order to speak well you cannot
just do input based activities and then
all of a sudden turn the switch on and
expect to speak well the purpose of the
input based activities which I favor the
purpose of these is to build up your
capability your potential for speaking
because you acquire familiarity with the
language you acquire vocabulary so that
when you finally decide whenever that
point is now I want to engage with
people now I want to speak you will have
a better chance of doing well and you
will then if you have gone through this
period of extensive listening and
reading you'll find that your progress
in speaking will be quite rapid that's
point number one so of
actually we do need to speak and we need
to speak a lot the second point is I
don't think it matters when you start
speaking there is some suggestion out
there that if you start to speak too
early you will ingrain bad habits and
that your bad habits will become
fossilized I have not seen any proof of
this this may be true it may not be true
I just don't know I do know that the
less stress we have the better we learn
so I find it much more pleasant to read
something at my own speed or listen to
something whenever I want and build up
my language capability rather than
having to confront a teacher or a native
speaker who's going to ask me questions
which I can't answer I prefer not to do
that but some people maybe have been
doing that so so that's fine I don't
think it really matters in the long run
the next thing is you often see people
say and even then the Benny the Irish
polyglot says you know here's how you
can learn to speak pretty well after two
months I have learned a number of
languages I don't think it's very easy
to learn to speak a language pretty well
after two months no matter what you're
doing I think it takes a long time to
learn to speak a language well you can
start speaking from day one and that's
not difficult you can get to the point
where you can say your name and ask
someone what their name is and how old
they are you can do that on the first
day that's not difficult but to me
speaking pretty well means that you can
talk about things other than the weather
that you can talk about a variety of
subjects genuine that genuine
communication can take place that takes
a long time so you can actually get to a
point earlier where you can understand
quite a bit and that is my preferred
strategy to get to where you can
understand and then you start speaking
and that your speaking will will
gradually improve and you need to speak
more and more and continue your input
activities so that the
the objectives say in two months with
the language let's say like Spanish or
French which is somewhat closer to
English is to get to the point where you
kind of got a toehold in the language
that you could in fact start speaking
and you would have enough words to have
a kind of a limited conversation
stumbling around ideally after two
months you are in a situation where you
can go out with a group of native
speakers and spend most of your time
listening and occasionally chime in with
something the idea that you could
actually all by yourself maintain it a
useful meaningful conversation after two
months I think that's expecting a lot
and I think it's is good that people be
aware that language learning takes time
and but it should always be fun so
therefore in a way if you like speaking
by all means speak right from the
beginning if you don't want it then you
don't have to and and so I think it's
realistic to think in terms of safer
Spanish and French to get to a point
after two months where you are starting
to be able to say some things you feel a
little more confident thanks to a lot of
listening and reading that you can start
talking a bit more to improve your
speaking so you know I I often hear this
question you know because my language
learning is based on input how do you
turn that into output well the fact is
that you continue with your input and
the input based activities remain the
main activities for for the longest time
simply because there's so much easier to
do you can always find a book you can
always listen on your ipod even after
you've reached the level where you are
comfortable speaking you'll have
normally you'll have far fewer
opportunities to speak then to listen
and read but when you do have these
opportunities and that's where I agree
very much with Benny don't be timid
don't be afraid don't expect to speak
correctly that speaking correctly won't
really matter what you want to then get
to is to where you enjoy communicating
and so you should put the focus on
communicating and and give yourself a
pat on the back when you are able to
communicate don't worry too much about
when you struggle to find words at which
you will do for a long long time and
continue to work on your understanding
because I still feel it's a much more
unpleasant feeling to be in a
conversation where you don't understand
what the other person is saying that is
much more unpleasant than stumbling
about feeling awkward not quite being
able to say exactly what you want to say
but somehow manage and get your meaning
across as long as you understand what
they're saying so in summary to speak
well you have to speak a lot you'll know
when you want to speak once you're in a
situation where you can speak make sure
that you take advantage of every
opportunity to speak and don't worry
about making mistakes so I don't know if
that makes any sense but there you have
it thank you for listening